it's a good evening my name is Hamilton
fish and on behalf of the nation
Institute it's my pleasure to welcome
you tonight to the new school University
here in New York City for a conversation
entitled the deepening shadow the u.s.
at war in the nuclear age we're
privileged to have with us tonight three
of the leading journalists of our day
whom I will introduce and I'd like to
start with Francis Fitzgerald in the red
frankie Fitzgerald has worked as a
journalist in the United States Vietnam
the Middle East Europe Central America
and the South Pacific her books include
fire in the lake the Vietnamese and the
Americans in Vietnam America revised
history schoolbooks in the 20th century
cities on a hill a journey through
contemporary American cultures way out
there in the blue Reagan Star Wars and
the end of the Cold War and Vietnam
spirits of the earth with photographs by
Mary cross the winner of the Pulitzer
Prize the National Book Award the
Bancroft prize for history among many
others Frankie's been a frequent
contributor to The New Yorker has
written for numerous other publications
including the New York Review of Books
the New York Times Sunday magazine
Architectural Digest islands and most
prominently the nation where she is also
a member of the editorial board
gentleman in the middle Chris Hedges a
senior fellow at the nation Institute
Chris joined the staff of the New York
Times in 1990 having previously worked
for the Dallas Morning News Christian
Science Monitor in the National and
National Public Radio he holds a BA in
English literature from Colgate and a
Master of Divinity from Harvard his
Elector and the Council of humanities
and Farris professor of journalism at
Princeton
it was a member of the New York Times
team that won the 2002 Pulitzer Prize
for explanatory reporting for the papers
coverage of global terrorism and he
received the 2002 Amnesty International
global award for Human Rights journalism
he's the author of war as a force that
gives us meaning which was a finalist
for the National Book Critics Circle
Award and what every person should know
about war by process of elimination
Jonathan Schell is Harold Willens peace
fellow at the nation Institute he's the
author of 12 books which have earned him
nominations for the Pulitzer Prize the
National Book Award and the National
critics Award as reporting on Vietnam
for The New Yorker included his
path-breaking essay the village of Ben
sook which helped turn US public opinion
against the war shells later books
include the 1982 bestseller the fate of
the earth hailed by the New York Times
as an event of profound historical
moment in 2003 his the unconquerable
world was described again in the New
York Times as perhaps the most
impressive argument ever made that there
exists a viable and desirable
alternative to a continued reliance on
war jonathan has published two more
recent titles with nation books the hole
in the world a collection of his letters
from Ground Zero columns from the nation
and his latest title the Jonathan shell
reader as I mentioned all three members
of tonight's panel will be available to
sign copies of their books which will be
for sale following the program outside
in the lobby Chris
Jonathan and Frank and I were speaking
before we came in about what we wanted
the heart of this discussion to be and I
think it's really how after the war in
Vietnam we've almost come full circle
and found ourselves caught of course in
another debacle another sort of again in
this overseas adventurism facing the
prospects of another imperial presidency
and we'd like to look back over the last
few years and find out what went wrong
and why we ended up here but I think I'd
like to begin on perhaps a more mundane
or prosaic level and just ask and
beginning with you Frankie how it is you
ended up in war how it is that you ended
up in Vietnam what it is that drew you
and how that experience changed you and
and what it taught you well I went to
Vietnam I'm almost by accident I thought
I'd like to go see Southeast Asia and I
was just starting as a journalist and so
I thought well I'll go and do a piece
for a magazine in Vietnam and then I'll
come home so I went there and I couldn't
leave and I was still there you know ten
months later when I finally had this had
to leave but then I really never left
the subject until the until the war
ended and and that was that was in 1966
Jonathan came a year later he was just
out of Harvard at the time he had no
credentials I didn't have any either
we've decided that we've lived our lives
in parallel
in many ways we both went to the Dalton
School in New York in fact our parents
were friends though we never met until
we were adults and we went to Harvard
and then we went to Vietnam so but we
was in a way our real matriculation then
we wrote about nuclear war yeah that's
right but but Jonathan you you went to
Vietnam and you immediately did too
extraordinary a series for The New
Yorker which became books of one on the
village of thenso and the other on the
air war in central Vietnam and I
wondered how you managed to do that
first of all how you dared to do it how
did you get there and how you imagined
it I mean how did you imagine doing the
those pieces which no one else was was
doing at the time well I didn't imagine
it because I was an even more accidental
journalist than you were
I actually arrived in Vietnam as a
tourist
I'd night spent a year and a half in
Japan sort of pretending to be a
graduate student and I had a ticket on
the way back that with the now-defunct
Pan American Airlines that permitted me
to stop anywhere I wanted in the world
and in as many places as I wanted in the
world so I chose Saigon Calcutta
Kathmandu and Oxford England
first up while Hong Kong first actually
then then Vietnam
I had no credential I had a very vague
idea that I might like to try to write
something but I did have one phone
number in my pocket because at college I
had met one Francoise su Lee French
journalist who was later killed in the
war I called up my one number he invited
me over to the Newsweek offices where I
was where he was working and I had under
my arm a book that people were reading
at that time by the great Barnard fall
on writer
French writer on Vietnam and there was
another gentleman there at Newsweek and
he said what are you reading and I said
well it's two Viet Nam's by Bernard
fault and he said may I see it so I
handed it to him and he opened it up and
he signed it that was
so and then sometimes I've actually been
asked by journals how do you get going
and in journals and I say well just try
to stumble into something you know just
that accident it's the best way anyway
they to cut make a long story short
these two marvellous high spirited
ebullient Frenchmen out of the sheerest
generosity of their hearts decided to
take on this definition of a nuisance
and a pest a sort of false graduate
student who thought he might like to
write something about a country he knew
nothing about and they got me a press
credential and one day they called me up
and said if you will come to a certain
gathering place at 3 a.m. in the morning
we'll get on the military bus and
something big is gonna happen it turned
out to be the largest military operation
of the war which was Cedar Falls it was
also the largest one ever mounted
because it was such a flop they didn't
care to repeat the experience so and
part of that war was that operation was
to attack and destroy the village of
Benson which had been occupied or
occupied had been governed by the
Vietcong for some decades I think really
the fort so I then went on that
expedition and and just simply gave a
first-hand account of what I had seen
that was it I was truly a trap EULA
ratha when I I was less knowledgeable
even than the normal fake graduate
student because I'd been in Japan they
speak Japanese in Japan I did learn to
speak it but I could not read it and
therefore I was cut off from the news
and so was pure shock I was entirely
naive and it was really just a
first-hand account without reflection
much really on what I saw what unfolded
in that village
well it's extraordinary it really really
was is a great piece of work in a system
so beautifully written if you get the
Jonathan Schell reader you'll find a
part of
good advertisement right but um I I mean
it I was just always been stunned by
that piece and and the following one
which you did at the same time that's a
no then I went back again later yeah
well how about you Chris I haven't I
I was in seminary and living in a
housing project in Roxbury I was gonna
be an inner-city minister and sort of
began to sour on the institutional
Church and Harvard Divinity School and
this was the time of the early 80s when
you had military dictatorships in Chile
and Archer deterred ivar in Argentina
war in El Salvador was heating up Somoza
had just fallen and I was drawn to Latin
America in in many ways through Orwell
and I felt that by going to Latin
America at that time it was as close as
my generation was going to come to
fighting fascism and and I I had very
close ties of course to the church
although as a Protestant to the Catholic
Church I lived with a Maryknoll fathers
in South America for a year but that was
really the you know what propelled me so
it was a little more ideologically
driven although unlike my colleagues I
was very critical of liberation theology
of any theological movement that
endorsed the use of violence to create
utopia having had Reinhold Niebuhr sort
of pounded into me but that's how I and
I spent six years in Latin America five
of them in our Salvador I want to ask
about the Vietnam War because I think
unlike I mean I I know you when you've
been in the Middle East and other places
I I after leaving El Salvador I lept
into several more conflicts and I always
found and until I was in Kosovo 20 years
later with people that I had actually
covered the war with in El Salvador and
one of the things I found was that well
going to your first conflict was
somewhat akin to losing your virginity
and there was a constant kind of search
I saw in foreign correspondents in other
conflicts to try and recreate the
passion
and in some ways recreate the experience
of understanding of course the the
hatred for war itself but and in some
ways they could never do it and I know
that you know Vietnam was not something
either of you gave up easily and I
wondered if you could address a little
bit about the impact that it had upon
you intellectually emotionally what it
did to you what did the experience do T
is that is it sorry to me yeah apart
from the the obvious
drama of what was going on with what
what really got to me was the mystery of
what was happening I mean when I arrived
there I just expected that all these
grown-ups I mean they're you know
military officers civilian officials
other journalists who know but knew
better than myself would would have
answers to simple questions such as why
was the army of South Vietnam defeated
you know in 1965 essentially and they
didn't have them and now maybe you find
out of course much later for Pentagon
Papers other documents much later on
that that people in Washington don't
know a good deal more than they were
saying at the time about about why the
other side puts winning in 1965 and they
had projected early on I mean in 1961
that didn't a lot of people thought it
would take several hundred thousand
American troops but I just didn't say
that so to some extent them it was a
kind of a willed ignorant that that
I arrived in Saigon and Saigon was was
full of people who were there for one
tour one year and I began to think that
I mean I actually my my my literary
queue was Conrad was that as it was for
Jonathan later on but its its firing
that shell out into the middle of the
jungle you know and as indeed they were
doing the night I arrived when some
television correspondent was giving a
birthday party for his girlfriend and so
we're on top of this Caravelle roof of
this wonderful hotel and there were
flowers and wine and everything and
there were border shelves going off
being fired into the jungle on the other
side of the river so and so I thought
this is this is it and I decided to not
to to do military reporting not to cover
troop battles and so on because I not my
comparative advantage as a woman at that
time but also what intrigued me was the
Vietnamese I mean what was going on in
this country that that the Americans
there didn't seem to be able to tell me
about
well you did that better than anyone has
done it since I might return the
compliment uh yeah I I of course did go
out and cover the troops and the battles
and uh and really metric amazingly few
Vietnamese to tell the truth I was in
the military bubble really as I say I
arrived there without many
preconceptions because of my ignorance
of course any war I think and just to
follow up what you were saying Chris is
is a fantastic shock for anybody who
goes into it and certainly it's a
lifelong shock at something that you
never even begin to get over exactly and
but I think that when the war is seems
to make no sense or when you can't
understand and when you can't fathom
those mysteries that Frankie talks about
then the shock is more profound because
it son palliated by the noble vision of
what it's supposed to be all about and
and I think in fact is to comment on
some of the reporting that what's going
on was I think the people who were more
knowledgeable than I if I may say so
we're perhaps a little bit disadvantaged
but I don't mean to be anti intellectual
against knowledge I believe in it but
certainly there was an understanding of
what was going on in the war a
mainstream understanding that was not
confirmed by what was happening on the
ground so there was the shock of the war
and then there was the shock of the
senselessness of it because the thing
even in terms of what I could see with
my own eyes happening for a minute a
minute just didn't hang together it
didn't make sense these questions you
know one if if we were supposed to be
saving the South Vietnamese people why
were we killing them and destroying them
just simple things like that though it
was it was very clearly and in detail a
self-defeating operation just to respond
to to what you said I did under
when I got back from that war that I was
obsessed with it and I could easily and
I saw others who were obsessed with it
and I actually made a deliberate
decision not to go back or to go to
another war at that time and part of the
reason was that I feared that obsession
which remains with me to this day
and certainly it was a seminal
experience in my life
and certainly that was the sort of
artillery troop that I was shot out of
so to speak and the long arc of my
writing
you know begins right there and it's
followed from it's something that makes
me uneasy by the way because I think a
formative influence can often be too
formative but I dare say that for the
country as a whole this war that War the
Vietnam where has that an amazing
staying power
/ - Eisley because we never succeeded in
coming to terms truly some did but most
did not I think with the truth of that
war sort of condemned to repeat it
because we can't face it or something
like that and it is is that because
there is a willful kind of forgetfulness
is there an attack against memory is
that what has happened you know I I
think memory becomes very selective and
you know if you read text books you know
modern high school history textbooks or
or you you sort of look look at what
appears now and then in the press in
terms of you don't do usually with
reference to Iraq what you see is that
yeah well I'm afraid just pretty much
what you saw then - which is this
incredible solipsistic
I mean it's all about the Vietnam War
was bad for America okay and it was but
there's no question about that
it was certainly bad for the American
army and you know every professional
soldier there knew it although they
weren't saying at the time but I mean if
you read Colin Powell's memoirs you know
he he tells us that it took him and and
other officers virtually 10 years to put
that army back together again
so there's um and goodness knows the
casualties uh you know the first of
first of all things but I think that you
know what selective is that is that we
don't remember what was important in the
war ie pop Vietnamese politics period I
mean you know the American troops as
hard as they fought in as much as they
died there we're almost irrelevant to
the conflict it was always going to be
what won or lost inside Vietnam and you
know selective memory - about about the
sheer amount of damage that we did to
that country yeah I was to go back to
your first question angry for ten years
and when I when the floor finally ended
I I said to myself I'm never ever gonna
be that angry again tried to what do you
think I mean do you I mean you know here
we we find ourselves in a situation as
the nation that has so many parallels to
where we were and is the route from that
is it caused by our our final inability
to to look at what happened is it well I
mean you said we'll forgetting and I
think that's absolutely right and and I
it's it's even the word forgetting seems
to me to be a little bit wrong because I
think there was a sustained and and
highly deliberate as well as unconscious
attempt actually to purge the lessons
so-called
of Vietnam after all they were called a
syndrome a sickness something that you
had to get over and I think we saw that
in the Reagan years but Reagan in other
words Vietnam was a defeat a defeat is a
very hard thing
to embrace there's a wonderful title of
the book about the occupation of Japan
about the Japanese by mr. I'm sorry
embracing defeat name will come to me
but the United States I don't think ever
accepted the defeat and there was an
effort thereafter and especially in the
Reagan administration perhaps you
witnessed this and in Latin America to
actually purge the lessons of Vietnam by
re-enacting some kind of a victory
somewhere so that we would no longer be
a defeated nation actually Reagan did
did less than you than he might if it
was covert it was under the table there
were no 500 thousand troops sent anyway
he sort of drew back many times from the
edge although sponsoring these dreadful
and horrific sort of covert efforts and
in Latin America I don't know what do
you perhaps Berenson I find that amnesia
which strikes a defeated country almost
immediately fascinating I saw it and for
the first time in Buenos Aires when I
covered the Falkland war but I saw it
again in Belgrade after the Serbs after
the NATO bombing broke the Serbs in
Bosnia and people just there was a
midsummer night's dream quality where
everything that had happened before
sometimes in the case of Bosnia for
three or four years didn't exist and
there's a there's a wonderful story I
think it's maybe in Churchill one of
Churchill's memoirs about after the end
of World War two the French inviting the
French military inviting their British
counterparts to come for lessons of the
war and the British show up and it's all
about World War one or if you now
remember visiting the Imperial War
Museum in Vienna and going through all
the rooms and finishing World War one
and asking where the exhibit on World
War two was and of course there isn't
one anywhere in Vienna anywhere in
Austria and I think that that that
for amnesia is something that strikes a
populace after a defeat and it it has
for those of us who who lived through
the conflict it has it turns it has a it
creates a bizarre reality in the case of
the United States of course it was not a
defeat on our soil so so that's
different from from but I think for a
period of five years actually it was
only five years there there was a real
sense right in the middle of Washington
and lovely among the Democrats but not
entirely that we never never do anything
like that again that and that did power
the imperial presidency had to be curbed
and and there were a lot of laws passed
at that at that time then there was the
oil shock the fall of the Shah a sense
that the Brezhnev was on the move
both diplomatically and otherwise and
that we were becoming this of what Nixon
called does do note that but isn't it
pitiful was giant yes
and when Reagan ran in in 1980 his
rhetoric was a most extraordinary
reversion to the past it it that
rhetoric could have come straight out of
the 1950s and it had all of the sort of
elements of of sort of the the American
a sort of civil religion in it which
Reagan spoke so very well but it was it
was saying that what we are renewing
here we are we are renewing the
country so that it will be the way it
was in the past it was very past
oriented yes absolutely yeah and and I
think people want to hear that at that
particular time they really wanted this
notion that we would be safe back in the
50s again I get turmoil in the United
States I think we've been going on as
well and and so he was essentially
preaching this this this this revival of
our national religion and at the same
time what's what was interesting about
it is that is that while while on one
hand it was saying he was saying Vietnam
didn't happen in this fashion military
and indeed the defense secretary Caspar
Weinberger were laying down a set of
rules and they literally you know it's
on paper we will never do this again we
won't ever go in without the support of
the American people without it with that
without overwhelming force without an
exit strategy etc etc etc and you can
find that in many places song but
including in the polls tells me more
yeah where the Weinberger's it's a great
saying about nationalism that it's often
based on forgetting a lot of things the
foundation of nationalism is to forget
all kinds of things and I think that
that's the sort of restoration that
Reagan offered was was very similar to
that at the same time you know and
you've written on this you know there
was a within the Reagan administration
this disconnect with reality and
you'd write a lot about SDI and how
there was this need to feel that were
protected even though of course it was
an impossibility and to what extent was
that the beginning of a widening
disconnect with our own reality in the
reality of the world that we live in
well I don't think the disconnect was
really in the Reagan administration I
think it's in ourselves
and Reagan understood that beautifully
he he understood he didn't even have to
look at the polls but if you look at the
polls going back it's in 1947 up to that
point if if American public was asked
can we have a defense against a nuclear
missiles everybody would say of course
but a half of them would be shocked that
we didn't have it already I mean what is
the Defense Department doing if it's not
defending himself or itself so you know
people really could could not swallow
the notion of deterrence the notion of
you know mutual assured destruction and
and so Reagan simply use that when
Jonathan Schell Jonathan Schell wrote an
extraordinary book and at that time when
did it come in 84 94 right the Reagan's
next election which was part of the and
helped create the anti-nuclear movement
at that time because okay they did the
earth was 82 you maybe that's what I was
thinking in favor they were so it's
early on in the anti-nuclear movement
that's right
and this movement became so large at the
time because I mean one of the things
that Reagan was doing was simply
building up our whole nuclear arsenal at
a great rate and and not talking to the
Russians at all and that made a lot of
people extremely nervous
so the anti-nuclear movement came from
Nora were very middle class became
enormous um spurred on by by Jonathan's
book just describing what what a nuclear
explosion would do
and then what happened
Reagan changed his whole message I had
in 84 it suddenly it became much more
positive opening world and he he he
simply made everyone forget that in fact
this nuclear build-up was going to going
on steadily by saying alright we're
gonna have this star wars we're gonna
have this wonderful shield over the
United States and he did it all by
himself
he wrote that speech all by himself and
the the few people who actually stood it
was just that actually it was a few
paragraphs at the end of it sort of a
normal defense speech the field people
saw it said you can't say that you can't
say that and he knew exactly how to say
that so that so that people would see
him as a man of peace yeah you know I
think what you say goes you know right
to the heart of a kind of a paradox of
American power really throughout the
nuclear age you never more acute than at
this moment which is that on the one
hand and now more so than ever we
consider ourselves to be the great
superpower the sole superpower the hyper
power and so forth and certainly nuclear
weapons are supposed to be a supreme
expression of that and yet when you
really look at it it turns out that
there's almost nothing that you can
actually do with them and at the same
time that we're the hyper power and the
super power we are hyper vulnerable it's
super vulnerable in our biggest
buildings to be knocked down by a couple
of airliners now that paradox was
present in Vietnam too
you mentioned the Nixon's phrase pitiful
helpless giant and so here we are all
bulked up with military force straddling
the world and we're supposed to be able
to get a terrific payoff out of that and
yet then we go to a tiny little country
Vietnam then now Iraq and it turns out
to be exceedingly difficult to work our
will for the reasons
that Frankie was alluding to namely that
what really counts in these countries is
the local politics and the US forces can
troop back and forth and kill all kinds
of people and destroy cities to save
them and all the rest of it and then at
the end of the day the people there is
and the less of the US stays there
forever just gonna do what they like so
I think the part of this forgetting this
aggressive forgetting that we're talking
about is is a cure for a fundamental
paradox and problem of American power or
indeed of any great military power in
our time which is that it it it tries to
find a way to restore the idea that we
are immensely powerful in a world in
which military strength actually doesn't
give you that kind of power and I think
we we've been struggling with that
problem psychologically you know
Secretary of State Dean Rusk once said
we're the greatest power in the world if
only we act like it so there it is were
the greatest but somehow there's a doubt
about it somehow we're falling through a
trapdoor we're not acting like why
aren't we acting like this because if we
act like it will blow up the whole world
ourselves included so it's not so easy
to act like it and then if you go and
try that a little bit as in Vietnam or
now in Iraq it turns out you get burned
and you don't even achieve the minor
exective x' that you set out to to go
back to salvador phenom because we're
talking about the reagan administration
there there some who have made parallels
between Iraq and El Salvador with the
notion being that free elections finally
triumph there and that this is this is
sort of good news for well the the of
course the the great outcome of the
Salvadoran elections is that they
elected Roberto Davis on the head of the
death squads of a Rana and who ran death
squads as president and then of course
the US Embassy worked behind the scenes
to make sure he never assumed office I
think I think there were a lot of
lessons in Central America that are
useful for understanding Iraq first and
foremost being of course that the United
States while it get pays lip service to
democracy that's sort of the last thing
that they want what they want is
malleable government that they can
control that has the appearance of
legitimacy which of course this interim
government does not but you know a
democratic Iraq is somebody who spent
seven years in the Middle East and a lot
of that time in Iraq would probably a
clerical II controlled Shiite Iraq with
very close ties to Iran and that's just
something that's never gonna happen in
terms of the fighting itself I think
there's a difference I think it out it
has probably a little more to do with
the Israeli occupation of Gaza in some
ways than the war in Central America
because of course we had surrogate
forces we had the Contras in Nicaragua
we had the Salvadoran army fighting
against the FMLN but we didn't actually
have American occupation forces on the
ground but having spent a lot of time in
Gaza one sees or very quickly becomes
aware of how dangerous that and what a
unifying factor that hostility is number
one and number two what happens when you
have an occupying force that has
disproportionate firepower that is able
to go to an urban environment or refugee
camp in Gaza and call in Apache
helicopters and the you know if you
haven't been in a war zone that the fact
that you're using Apaches to attack
houses and honey eunice
doesn't mean anything but for those of
us who've watched Apaches these are
flying tanks is what they are I was in
the last tank battle of the Gulf War and
the entire Iraqi tank division was wiped
out essentially by Apaches and or the
fact that you use f-16 fighter jets to
bomb Jabalia
and that's what's happening in Iraq that
it's that escalation of massive
firepower you know the fact that you're
walking into a slum in Fallujah and
unleashing with 50 caliber machine guns
and of course they worked very hard so
that we don't know the numbers of the
dead but I think it touches on the
frustration you're talking about and and
of course that only galvanizes I mean
what we have done is taken a very
fractured country and created a very
unified rebellion against that
occupation and I think that in in some
ways it bears a lot of similarity to
what the French went through in Algeria
you know you go through the airport in
Algiers and it says welcome to Algeria
the land of a million martyrs and when
you live under that kind of degradation
and I think that's something that you
got so well in your book you know that
the problem with the people running this
enterprise is then there's that
wonderful essay by Danny Lakeisha about
how all nationalists are inherently
ignoramuses because they only see the
world as a reflection of their own
national everybody's and nationalism
just like them
a nationalist just like them and I think
that you know without an understanding
of the communal ties the family ties the
true you know the undercurrent of the
society their perspective of reality we
can only speak in the language of force
and an escalating language of force and
one that dooms us because they let the
big lesson you learn in El Salvador when
you walk away from that conflict after
five years that the best recruiting
weapon the rebels had were martyrs were
the desk watts they're the the the best
recruiting weapon the FMLN had were the
Salvadoran disciplines and I'd like to
talk a little bit about Iraq in
specifically and
and what parallels you see with Vietnam
if any and what differences you see and
in the way the conflict is proceeding
well you just brought up some some
similarities so I'll go for differences
this election that's just been passed
but we just had in Iraq there was never
anything like it and yeah dumb and for
for a simple reason that we were we were
trying in in Vietnam to suppress a an
indigenous revolution and so therefore
those people were by definition not
allowed to vote and nor was anyone else
who was even on the margins so we never
had a free election in in Vietnam and it
would have because our entire purpose
was to was to to say save this a non
communist regime in Iraq that seems to
be a little different because while we
clearly when I say we I the
administration does not want Sodom was
saying to come back again again but
there's it's there's not a parallel
situation and that in that they don't
want to suppress the Sunday's of the
Shia or Fitness knows the Kurds and you
know at this point you know people talk
brave I mean the president will keep on
talking gravely about democracy but what
they would really like is for the Iraqis
to make some kind of a deal of those
Iraqis who who think that that there
should be a stable government and an end
to the insurgency so the issue is my
view whether whether those who were
elected were mostly share of course can
actually make that deal themselves
because we're not going to be able to do
it for them make it with with the Sunni
whoo-hoo
and make them feel that they will be
part of that they
a new a new Iraq can that happen
I would hate to try and predict that one
but I it seems to me that the u.s. role
in terms and in terms of Iraqi politics
about a different then yeah I thought
that that sounds right to me I think
that the what what'll the comparison
that is that is there and that holds
true is that the local politics whatever
they are are going to dominate at the
end of the day but those local politics
are fundamentally different because in
Vietnam you had a sustained United
historically deeply based revolutionary
independence movement that had already
defeated one foreign power the French
and you had and now is targeting the
next one the United States and also
there was half of the country that was
under the control of the of that
movement namely North Vietnam and then
behind them several superpowers China
and Russia layer upon layer well that
was far different from Iraq and and
quite honestly I don't feel able like
like Frankie to make a prediction I
don't feel so expert in that area of the
world but what's apparent is that Iraq
right now is not does not have that kind
of incredible national unity that the
Vietnam and the meze had what it has is
a fractured society and the fractures
seem to be deepening and on the one hand
clearly the election did evoke an
emotion from the Iraqis that was unlike
anything we saw in in in Vietnam I
happen to witness one of these so-called
elections in Vietnam I went to it a
province Ventre I think it was and there
was this election that was going on in
1967 and I went out there in this sort
of muddy streets and nobody was there
nobody was there and then it turned out
the candidates had got stuck somewhere
else and some others
city and there was this rally ground no
people had come no candidates would come
but there was one little old man who had
a strange contraption of bullhorn
old-fashioned not electronic just like a
dunce cap that was strapped to his
shoulders by a strange metal apparatus
and he was going up and down the streets
they come to the election rally come to
the election round and I was with the
with the the boys on the bus at that
time and there were like 40 or 50
reporters there they had nothing to show
except this one little so that was the
election in South Vietnam just no
candidates no voters just this little
old man at all the Western news people
trying to pretend that something was
happening well that's far different in
Iraq so so it's a different politics
I was thinking takasaka who is what a
wonderful Japanese correspondent in
Vietnam recorded a remark he heard from
one of the villagers after that election
in 67 the villagers said you know every
every vote is sort of is like a feather
and when we put all the feathers on
these candidates they fly away and we
never see them before I open it up to
questions which we will do I just want
to ask both of you to back up a little
bit and talk about this coming
proliferation of nuclear weapons
not just in North Korea but having spent
a year of my life covering al-qaeda
certainly it's the feeling among many
intelligence officers that it there it
is probably inevitable that some of
these route groups who are arrayed
against us will get their hands on at
least crude version of these weapons
dirty bombs etc and are we entering
perhaps an apocalyptic age are we
entering an age unlike one that we have
seen before and how are we preparing for
go ahead John well I do think that the
that with the theme that that nuclear
danger it's sort of like a steel spine a
hidden steel spine around which events
have a have revolved really going back
since to 1945 and I think we're in a new
chapter and that evolution I think at
the heart of it is our we're talking
about willful ignorance our resolute
determination not to see and grasp the
meaning of the fact that we ourselves
have a great mountain of nuclear weapons
still in this world and that so do the
Russians and the French and the Chinese
and so on and so forth and now the North
Koreans and the Indians and the
Pakistanis the way I see it as long as
we're unable to see the nuclear weapons
that are in existence we're not going to
be able to persuade other people not to
bring new ones into existence so I think
we've now entered a period of stepped-up
proliferation very clearly North Korea
being the latest to announce any way
that it's crossed the finish line Iran
as seems to be on its way as far as we
can tell and it it appears once again
that this is moving like a to the center
of things of like an axle on which
events are turning because after all
what was the Iraq war all about spewed
Italy it was about weapons of mass
that's how it was sold to the country
and to the world after all the
resolutions at the UN and at Congress
mentioned this they didn't talk about
democracy in Lebanon
they talked about weapons of mass
destruction and so also that's the theme
for several other prospective Wars which
I like to call disarmament wars which
which may lie in our future starting
with Iran although it's not so clear
that they simply have the wherewithal to
do with that but certainly the doctrinal
foundation has been laid so as long as
you don't have a handle on that control
of that it's going to control you and
now it's doing so in a new way just as
it did in the Cold War in another way
where really that we the United States
and the Soviet Union weren't unable to
stop the arms race between us until the
Cold War ended and really until
Gorbachev appeared and the gold were and
then they began to tail it down although
let's remember that we still have some
you know 32,000 nuclear weapons in the
world today people forget that they just
forget that entirely passes out at they
month but there they are
so so if that that's where I think we
are now I think that nuclear weapons and
the other weapons of mass destruction
but still above all the nuclear are in
the saddle again in a whole new way in
this whole proliferation Nexus I put
terrorism aside for a moment just and
talk about the state control them but
because it seems to me that end of the
Cold War comes and suddenly we have a
very much simpler view about what power
is than we use have you touched on this
before military power is power period
who was it calls calls the book so the
Bush
the bush people the wacom moles right
nothing just go and take it out and it
comes back up again and you know if
you've just whack it so it's not yeah
but I think that that that they've
they've they've come to the end of of of
this logic because not only are we
bogged down in a walk but clearly we
have been going backwards in terms of
North Korea simply because they they
refuse suit to enter into negotiations
of any sort of timing that North Koreans
who are you know all kinds of cheating
and all kinds of things go on I mean
lemon not making them in the States but
the point is the the that the Clinton
administration was able to use threat
and carrot and so on and we've always
this the Bush administration just
refuses the carrots and it's now I think
finally coming around to the Europe nor
the European position on on Iran because
there's simply nothing else to do and
they're taking the only choice they have
the other one is simply to do nothing
there's no there's no military solution
there any more than there is in Korea so
you know if that gets through you know
that there is actually more to power
than simply trying to counter
proliferation as the word then then
where I think we may be getting
somewhere if I like and there is not the
way there was in the Cold War a sort of
unalterable sense that that most of the
world um in the mid that this that the
nuclear superpowers are unalterably
ideologically opposed and so therefore
there's you know at least some political
basis that didn't didn't exist before
terrorism thing is in
is another matter and and and a scary
one because we have so done so little
with non-proliferation thus far
including you know trying to try to to
mop up the loose nukes in in Russia that
we're way behind on that and well you
tell us what the what what is being said
there's a there's a deep fear that that
is just a question of time until crude
versions of these apocalyptic weapons
fall into the hands of groups who are
very hungry used let's take a few
questions and we have mics so please
wait until the microphone comes in the
green sweater here right right here I
think can you wait to speak into the
microphone hi I think that when we're
talking about nuclear weapons the United
States is guilty of not only making them
but using them so to talk about
terrorism and this country is trying to
get it that country is almost getting it
that country we haven't negotiated with
this is all bogus for a country this
size with arsenal this big we should set
the agenda we should say we're not going
to make any more bombs instead of saying
we're making bomblets nucleus because so
this way if we can get you I'm gonna try
and get you and not maybe you so this is
at this discussion I don't know I don't
think anybody here disagrees with you do
you have a question you want to have
daughter Jonathan no I don't think any
of us disagree with you
good let's let Jonathan this is his area
and any
Milas my question is do you think that
countries that have nuclear weapons
should all agree to stop making them and
stop using them and plus get rid of the
ones they have I do yes see I think the
problem is which you have expressed is
that I as a moral matter certainly but
also as a practical matter I don't think
that a double standard can stand I don't
think that the house divided can stand
so you you can't have a world in which
those who sit on top of great piles of
nuclear weapons are giving angry
lectures to those who are trying to
climb up the slopes of those piles and
get to just a few themselves I just
don't think it's it's workable so you
have to go to a single standard and I
think that the world will go to a single
standard the question is what is it
going to be that anybody who wants them
can have them that's where we're headed
right now or is it going to be that
everybody goes together after a long
hideously difficult political military
diplomatic economic process emitted Lee
a tall mountain to climb
but that at the end of the day nobody
has them and that and that is the in my
opinion the only workable regime and I
say that of course it's an idealistic
thing it's highly idealistic to imagine
sucessfully which nobody and any
government that I've heard of is really
thinking about seriously to be perfectly
honest about it and yet I say that as a
matter of the coldest realism because in
addition I'm not bothering about making
it a moral statement it is a moral
statement when you're when you're
dealing with these hideous weapons but
it is also a practical matter so my
message to those who say well you know
we can't get rid of them I said all
right then get used to proliferation and
to this terrorists falling into the
terrorist hands if that's your position
then accept the consequence be realistic
about it and tell us what you're going
to do about that and and I think the
important thing in raising the issue of
the possibility of terrorist groups
using weapons of mass destruction is
that it then becomes the excuse that we
seize upon to use weapons of mass
destruction that's the danger that we
fall into in a kind of apocalyptic
nightmare where our apocalyptic
visionaries are matched against their
apocalyptic visionaries and and
certainly the point you make is a
correct one but we may very well be
facing very soon a world where these
weapons or crude versions of them are
being used and and and having lived in
Israel through the suicide bombings when
people are afraid and they stop thinking
it all becomes how can we stop the
vermin out and who can we grasp within
our society Oriol cherone who will do it
for us I'm not picking on the Israelis
no society is any different having lived
through the war in Yugoslavia and other
conflicts but I don't think that's
something we've stopped and thought
about and we have to begin to think
about it and though in the red sweater
over here oh go ahead BAM thank you what
can we do in terms of legal structures
that exists to like promote this for
instance the non-proliferation treaty is
coming up this April and we promised in
that treaty to get rid of our
I mean how can we kind of get people
back to sanity as the nation of laws I
mean have you seen that playing out it
seems like we're kind of losing our grip
on our legal operation
well this administration has been
against all arms control treaties from
from the beginning so it really it's a
political problem it's not you know it's
a political problem in this country it's
a political problem in some other
countries as well so you know obviously
the the legal part of it is the end
process honey in the glasses
hi my question is for mr. shell I agree
with you you're saying about you know
all these all the countries getting
together oh can you hear me now yeah
great it's not like I got that
commercial now but my question is I mean
how do you envision that logistically I
mean how do you think that these
governments will sort of sit around
together and actually get down to the
business of agreeing on getting rid of
their nuclear weapons I mean I agree in
principle it sounds wonderful but how
would it work just sort of the short
version of hi how do you think it would
work yeah I think what Frankie says is
true
the the the Himalaya that stands in the
way is the political problem it's it's
finding the will developing the will the
technical side of it is quite doable
already we're down about 50% so keep
going and do the other 50% now there all
kinds I don't want to minimize the
difficulties of what does a world look
like at 500 200 that's zero and so forth
it's fantastically complex and difficult
I won't go into it all but it's it's
it's doable but the problem is doing it
is having the having the will to do it
now how might that come about I said
before that there's scarcely I but I
misspoke when I said that there are not
people in governments who want to do
this because there are a hundred and
eighty-two countries in the world under
the nuclear non-proliferation treaty
which Ellis later over here was
referring to which have decided as a
matter of national policy to do without
nuclear weapons
that's a lot of countries and that would
be absolutely delighted the majority of
them if the nuclear powers would go down
the path that they are on all of South
America is nuclear weapon free and they
are nuclear weapon capable and they went
up the slope and then they got a little
look looked at what that looked like and
then they went down again they went back
down again so it can be done but just to
make one final comment about the
practicability or where that will might
come from in the 1990s everybody just
forgot about
we're weapons nobody thought about it
not Bill Clinton not the man on the
street not the diplomats not the
foundations everybody just forgot about
it not so today
both Kerry and Bush when asked what was
the most important issue in the third
debate whatever debate I said it was
nuclear proliferation I would add
possession but at least they got got it
half right not only that but the thing
is in play it's in process in many
countries around the world and it's not
just Iran in North Korea Edythe there
muttering in Brazil about you know there
so they don't want to have their
facilities inspected there in Japan you
know there are few people on the
sidelines of government who are talking
about it
Japan's capacity in Japan is ready to go
they've got the plutonium they've got
everything anyway the point is that
there's the process under way and there
are consequences and already North
Korea's crossed the finish line now how
bad the breakdown has to get before
somebody says wait a minute we're on the
wrong path I don't know but the evidence
is piling up and we'll continue to pile
up in the back go ahead sir
hello I think that was missing I thought
in the discussion this evening but the
discussion the media's role in the
attitude of the American people that
sort of came about by itself or by
Reaganism of I uh understand the Vietnam
War and a different light but there been
no discussion at least from the three of
you guys about and women sorry about the
situation in in the media which is
absolutely intolerable including the New
York Times mr. hedges I'm very sorry to
say you know I was at work for ABC for
16 years I'm 18 years very on proud of
it they're large riffles things there as
the New York Times as continues to do
really dreadful thing
it's a highbrow piece of rubbish as
opposed to the Amish but it's a piece of
rubbish are the same and fools of people
constantly and I understand you need to
make a living like I needed to make a
living how to put kids from college and
what happened but anyway go make up all
right well let's move will the dress to
me I was out the door like you I know
and I remember someone reporting from El
Salvador you know and it was certainly
unfavorable to the people who are trying
to overthrow the quote quote people
there that control sorry Thanks well
look we'll talk about the okay to say
that let me let me go five years ago
will address the media issue oh did you
know that the New York Times in 1998-99
fact the Filipino a annexation at the
course of 750,000 Filipino lives did you
know that all right thank you very much
well let's the dress I mean you know the
issue of the media is an important one
and the role the media and I you know
it's something that I wrote about in my
own book and I know you have dealt with
as well you know the problem is that in
almost all wars the media becomes part
of the problem the media and I and
having reported conflicts from my own
country is not directly involved and
reported conflicts where they are
directly involved once your own nation
goes to war there is a kind of feeling
among the media that they have that
their job is to promote that patriotic
myth that myth of glory and honor and
courage and and when you walk into a
situation it's almost like they look for
those set character roles that they can
place on the stage and recreate over and
over and over there's a you know I think
it's LaShawn and his book talks about
the difference between
sensory and abstract notions of war and
that we don't get sensory war reporting
when our own nation goes to war but
these abstract notions where we use
these very hollow abstract terms such as
the ones I just laid out for you honor
of glory heroism all this kind of stuff
and that he would argue that eventually
the war in Vietnam became a sensory
conflict where people no longer could
buy into the myth anymore and the press
was free to report in a sensory manner
which is just the brutality of war
itself but I think if you go back all
the way back to the Crimean War where
arguably the first war correspondent was
invented it has been a shameful period
of reporting and I include the Spanish
Civil War from the Republican side you
know and and and the lie of war is often
the lie of omission it's all the things
they don't tell you or show you and I
think that you know those few courageous
souls
you know I sit next to two of them who
go out and actually try and report on
war as it is often have to work on the
very margins of the press of the media
itself media questions always drive me
nuts in a way because because you know
there's it's not one thing it's a vast
world out there they're an awful lot of
good reporters in it look at Seymour
Hersh
from me lie that have them cram you know
with there is a way in which we get to
know things that and then we criticize
the media but somehow we got to know
those things through the media so and it
seems to me that if you know if if you
read enough and really it is probably
operative word here that you that you
can find out a lot of things and if you
read and in there in the skeptical
fashion and look beyond this you know
you get to know how reporting is done
and then it's it's out there to find you
know sometimes there are there are
periods when it isn't and the period
before the Iraq war was was was a
particular period when there was very
little but even even at the time even at
the time one could pretty well say gee
whiz I doubt that Iraq has nuclear
weapons I doubt that they have a nuclear
program that said that's because that
was was what was also being reported Oh
make that just two quick comments
one is that of course pressure of every
kind on the media you know nationalist
popular pressure commercial pressure
governmental pressure and all three
going together produce a very bad
resulted I think certainly in my memory
this period of the Iraq war has been the
very worst period in terms of media
coverage that I've seen but you know if
you go back to the first world war or
for that matter this the
spanish-american war that produced the
occupation of the Philippines you'll
find as Chris I think is suggesting
you'll find many of these same thing my
second comment is that there's a
solution to all this read the Nation
magazine
right here on the road can you hear me
take it I've lost my voice so I ask you
could you talk about the economic motive
the thing that has struck me about the
recent several years is dr. Khan and
Pakistan
many of us have remembered other times
but it seems that dr. Khan's motive was
strictly financial that we have a free
market here that is out selling these
weapons to whomever wants them sure
well the head about the International
Atomic Energy Agency Mohamed ElBaradei
referred to the Khan
that's the Pakistani scientist who was
proliferating nuclear know-how all over
the world referred to that operation as
a nuclear of Walmart and I I agree with
that I was very startled to learn that
someone so high up could be so much
inspired by a commercial motive now I
suspect by the way that that isn't the
only one because there's no one who
believes that that was done without the
knowledge of the fact standing
government one of the black holes of
journalism right now is or government
policy or understanding is to know
really what that operation was who is
involved in the Pakistani government
over a long period of time operating in
Dubai and Malaysia Iran Iraq Libya all
over the place really an amazing
operation but but to fully understand
that operation which was certainly the
most egregious example of proliferation
and of loose nukes and everything else
that you can imagine that that story has
not been
we're very surprising to me he was
building been building villas all over
the Middle East with the proceeds from
his centrifuges will do just two more
questions let's get this gentleman back
here in the event that history goes down
this unfortunate route can you recommend
a good up-to-date source of civil
defense information that's appropriate
to 21st century scenarios most of what
I've seen was published like in 1950s
when it was a question of massive attack
by super powers if we see a flash on the
horizon what do we do next
good civil defense to offer Frankie no I
don't know and don't actually the only
thing I can think of I'm certainly not
gonna say because it has to do it
probably not not being quite so near
this very built this neighborhood yes
sir
yeah my question is what is it narc I I
live in England and I'm an American what
is it in our culture that prevents us
from reporting as clearly and as
aggressively the truth that the British
press seems to handle there is a channel
channel for which is a commercial
channel in Great Britain and it handles
Abu Ghraib it handles terrorism and it
handles the forthrightness I think
you're a little too tentative for me
saying well they're commercial
consideration why are we not a bit more
aggressive it is possibly to be so and
tell the truth
well I think I agree with you that the
British press has been better than the
American President and you can find out
a lot in the British press that you did
you don't find out here and it's more
prominently displayed and so on
especially with regard to Abu Ghraib in
the war and so forth well but I think
that all of the pressures that that make
for bad coverage are more intense in the
United States at this moment than they
are in Britain I think everybody really
knows that this is an American war and
that the British are sort of tagging off
tagging or they're not invested in it in
the same way certainly in public opinion
they are not and so I think that there's
and also they didn't experience
September 11th which is the fuel the
political fuel that the Bush
administration uses in its campaign with
the American public even down to this
day so I just think it's a the pressures
are just far more intense here and
probably that's the reason
I would do one one last question that
right right here this woman in the back
row
the one thing I haven't been
haven't really heard is beneath all this
the economic impact of the Iraq war on
Iraq where I understand that the oil
industries are now privatized and in
general you know this seems to be like
an avoidance of saying anything that
might smack up a Marx Marxist analysis
of international capitalism of the lack
of governmental structures to deal with
any of these things with the you know
see it in the interview with Condoleezza
Rice she was she had nothing too good to
say about Venezuela and Cuba and it was
really disturbing to me I don't remember
which senator or senators was just can
you go right to the budget deal with her
frustrated okay what's the question so
the question is what can be done to
address what's really happening here I
mean we have basically taken a Content
okay why isn't anything being said about
this all right you want to know well you
know the economic motive is ever-present
and hugely powerful you know you were
almost silenced if you dared to suggest
that the Iraq war had anything to do
with oil you know what what I wanted to
answer to that facetiously is that oil
has been a central concern of the United
States certainly since 1945 when FDR
made a special visit to King Vince out
to make sure that we would sit for our
supplies there and and you can go down
through history in many volumes showing
the Carter doctrine and
that's 1979 to preserve the Persian Gulf
of vital interest of the United States
and all the rest of it right down to the
red so the idea that they suddenly
forgot about oil at exactly the moment
they were heading into a country but the
second-largest reserves is simply absurd
but it's absolutely absurd so and I
suppose in order to understand what the
motivation was and how it figures in
exactly we'd have to wait until some
Pentagon Papers of this period would
come out whether they were afraid that
the oil countries would put their dollar
dollars in your you know euros instead
of dollars or whatever the
considerations there are many theories
about it I suppose we won't have the
specific answers but to suggest that the
business interests in oil are not a
powerful impetus here would just be to
deny the history of the last 50 years
well the irony is of course that this
invasion is actually endangered oil
supplies and in the far more than they
would have been otherwise degradation of
the Iraqi oil oil fields threat to Saudi
oil field still because Saudis are
worried about the Iranians they've been
it possibility of a conflagration
arrived in the Gulf this is one possible
outcome of this war so you know it
turned out not to be the most efficient
way to deliver oil no I forgot to say my
facetious thing which was if they aren't
thinking about oil they should be
impeached we're gonna run away or
another we're gonna turn it over to him
thank you very much
thanks to this wonderful panel this
evening thanks to the new school for my
use of facilities co-sponsoring this
event - c-span and it's a wonderful
audience for helping our Americans in
England to realize that there's
diversity in the media in this country
and please stay tuned for a future
nation Institute panels thank you very
much thank you